is it coming home like it did in 1966
well Skye's data team looks at
everything from the economy to the state
of the NHS but we've also crunched the
numbers to see how the England men Squad
flying out to Qatar compared to players
of previous years have a look at this
football pitch that we've mocked up it
tells us if ground Southgate is taking a
more attacking or more defensive Squad
each line represents a different England
squad the closer to the goal line the
more Defenders picked now the 2018
Russia World Cup squad is all the way
down here the most defensive but look
where this year's Squad sits eight
forwards in the squad actually make it
the most attacking lineup since 1962.
now England's form going into this
tournament has been pretty atrocious but
does that matter historically if you
look down the table keep looking down
keep looking down they are actually the
worst we've ever been in the run-up to a
World Cup hardly promising but all is
not lost the squad at the top in 1950
they had the best run into a tournament
they didn't make it out of the group
stages although the 1966 Squad won all
of theirs before they went on to win the
whole thing and regardless of how
they've done what we want to see over
the next few weeks is goals we've
averaged out all the players
international goals in their career up
to the start of a World Cup further to
the right the more goals that Squad had
under the belt as they began their
campaign it might not be a surprise of
the winning 1966 Squad had the most
goals on average in the lead up 5.8 per
player 2022 squad has an average of 4.5
which isn't too shabby we can also look
at the mix of the squad in terms of the
levels they play at for their Club 12
different Club sides are represented
among the 26. the best years 2006 and
2014 they would have had an average
league position of fourth in 1966 always
keep going back to that the average was
10th although the league did have two
more teams back in it back then and this
year we are looking at six so a bit
lower than it has been in previous years
that is what the data shows us and we'll
be keeping an eye on it throughout the
world cup over the next few weeks